il annonce de son décès voilà où vous
voulez on voulait absolument lui rendre
hommage ce soir parce que l'annoncé de
son décès nous a tous touchés
qu'on fasse de la politique ou pas on
sait qu'il était à droite mais c'était
un personnage très sympathique
vraiment c'est un des présidents les
plus basses et bah c'est le premier
président wade c'est un des présidents
les plus sympathiques voilà qu'on ait
connu c'était de nombreux moments cultes
et on va vouloir montrer ce soir parce
que on a notamment des moments cultes
des guignols alors quand on repense
souvent moins culte bien sûr de jacques
chirac on pense ou lie aux guignols et à
yves lecoq et venir nous rejoindre dans
un instant on voulait revenir sur
plusieurs skate qui nous ont marqués au
souvient tous du célèbre oise à une pub
un moment voilà il avait repris pour
jacques chirac c'était en 2001 was as et
what's up bien sûr en anglais comment ça
va en français merci bien sûr bilingue
[Musique]
rien je regarde un match bonne bière et
toi non
justin bieber attend alors besoin
[Musique]
là
à
waouh
le président un bien qu'est ce qui vous
arrive alors c'est un truc de base et là
tu peux pas comme beaucoup voilà et yves
lecoq vous étiez la voix des guignols on
va on va en parler ici parce que c'est
vrai que ça représente tout ce quelque
chose pour nous la mort de jacques
chirac
je ne connaissais pas un français qui
n'était pas triste mine aux aimants ce
matin à qui ça n'a pas fait quelque
chose parce que c'est vrai que je l'aï
dit tout à l'heure
qu'on soit de n'importe quel bord
politique jacques chirac ou les mais
quoi qu'il arrive franchement tout le
monde l'aimé que ce soit à gauche ou à
droite et on a vu au niveau des hommages
des personnalités tant de gauche que de
droite lui ont vraiment rendu un bel
hommage
yves lecoq merci d'être là somme qui ont
indiqué l'avoir j'aime beaucoup je suis
très content de vous voir et c'est vrai
que vous avez été une vraie combien
d'années vous avez fait la voix de
jacques chirac à 30 ans puisque ça fait
30 ans que l'ignoble on a commencé le
premier jour à faire chaque quand il
était maire de paris et l'époque et puis
il ya eu la période avant des élections
95 avec le duel balladur qui avec vous
l'après une ampleur incroyable
on l'a dit qu'on l'avait aidée à passer
parce que parce que il était sympathique
et rendu sympathique par ces mots et
parce qu'on lui rajouter vous l'avez
rencontré j'ai rencontré avant avant des
guignols et après ça je me suis interdit
de le rencontrer justement parce qu'ils
mettaient sympathique et je voulais pas
qu'on donne donner l'impression je le
soutenais parce que je voulais rester
livre de de tout ce qu'on dit souvent
que les guignols ont aidé jacques chirac
a gagné l'élection présidentielle c'est
vrai que en 2001 on se rappelle bien
vous n'arriviez pas en 2000 aussi
c'était vraiment c'était lui d'ailleurs
c'était le personnage principal des
guignols et en 2001 jacques chirac avait
été photographiée nue au fort de
brégançon alors qu'il était sur son
balcon et ça avait fait beaucoup parler
ça m'inspire et les guignols vous
rappeler de ça ou pas vous allez les
dépeint une allocation une allocution du
président qui a expliqué pourquoi il
avait été pris en photo nue regardez
dans ces français chers compagnons
j'en ai été photographiée nue à poil
quoi à brégançon par des photographes
indélicats et saint tropez
on dirait qu est ce que le président la
république foot est un poil sur sa
terrasse avec des jumelles en train de
mater d'un yacht rang pitch claude ma
fille m'a conseillé trouve une
explication vite
1 oui françaises français j'ai qu'un
seul si chirac je peux finir c'est un
site très vieux très beau que j'aime
beaucoup c'est mon slip de l'armée
kangourou coton un peu lâche aux crises
mais qui maintient des chirac et comme
je n'ai que celui là je le porte
un jour je la 3e le port un jour je là
pas de chance pour les photographes ils
sont tombés le jour de lessive
voilà ce qu'il paraît que c'était votre
membres qui se vautre moments préférés
mais oui parce que là j'en ris encore
parce que j'ai on oublie tout ces
détails là il y en a eu tellement en 30
ans et c'est vrai que quand on annonce
et chirac cogiter moi je me régalais
d'avancé le savait que ça allait être
drôle parce que le personnage a une
force comique incroyable saviez vous
allez avoir beaucoup beaucoup de
d'inspiration voilà au taux de
chargement rappel en 2000 les guignols
avait fait une parodie du film tigre et
dragon avec jacques chirac et lionel
jospin lionel jospin était l'ancien
premier ministre de jacques chirac après
ils se sont affrontés lors de l'élection
présidentielle en 95 et lionel jospin a
knife à passer le premier tour
c'était le sketch du tigre au parler de
la fraiseuse et le cha cha oui le shaq
et kate regardez
pour réussir est en 2002 et vous vous
échouerez âme en peine
oui mon bilan est meilleur ah ouais et
en plus vous est empêtré dans les
affaires
je n'empêcherai pas la justice de
travailler et bien se peignent
[Musique]
[Rires]
giggs et chat [ __ ] un film avec un gars
qui lui reste que son peigne et qui veut
le garder il était extrêmement
sympathique il paraît que vous avez eu
un fou rire un jour en jacques chirac
non les fous rires on en arrive à
l'aller jamais je suis à un moment vous
êtes dit watts à ces jeux se situe en
direct dans les guignols
j'aurais pu la voir mais il y avait
quand même il fallait se tenir coi
impossible de rire de soi donc il
fallait que ce soit ça paraît sérieux
m'est arrivé ne tromper de voie des
choses comme ça mais le fou rire on l'a
toujours évité il a déjà essayé de
contacter les guignols pour leur dire
voilà vous en faites trop ou peut-être
mais non je pense que lui justement
c'est pour ça que je les salue à la fin
de son règne on va dire parce que je ne
voulais pas de rapports amicaux avec
puis tout du long
ça a été ma priorité et je suis allé le
voir pour lui dire en quelque sorte
merci deux arts foutu la paix parce que
il nous a justement jamais dieu sait si
ses collaborateurs certains plus petit
lui qui disait monsieur chirac foire
était folle et s'arrêter et répondait
laisser l'est ce sont des enfants et
donc c'est vrai que c'était ça c'est
qu'il attendait pour des gosses qu'on
était en étaient des sales gosses mais
c'était ça alors vous mettiez aussi en
scène sa femme bernadette ont vraiment
bossé le sketch à l'eau centrale on y
voit un petit rap de jacques et
bernadette ensemble regardez j'ai
débarqué de la corrèze peau mais alors
faut pas me faire ch
les le siège en est allé voter 2002
ok je vais me présenter on m'appelle
chirat il laisse tout de même à
connaître
bah oui g gross et bourgeoise et reggae
tiken jah redeviennent mimiques
connaîtra les gros fail to jouera les
méchants c'est beau chirac bernadette
soûlé mana s'être cassé nous rappelle
péter sont ceux qui paient ces boues
sympa mais c'est vite et c'est vrai
qu'on voulait rendre un hommage à
jacques chirac notre président mais de
façon divertissante on va vous montrer
plein de choses plein de trucs très très
drôle parce que jacques chirac c'est
vrai que c'est aussi on l'aimé aussi
pour ses gaffes ce qu'il veut y faisait
plein de gaffes et ça vous servez
notamment dans les guignols puisque yves
lecoq est notre invité yves lecoq était
la voix de jacques chirac dans les
guignols et c'est vrai que on a
l'impression quand on voit en parle
aujourd'hui que vous prenez un véritable
plaisir je pense que vous l'aimez bien
obligatoirement il y avait une sympathie
parce que moi je ne jugeait pas l'homme
et ses actes manqués on peut dire je
jugeais uniquement le fait qu'il était
bon qu'il existait sympathique et qu'il
avait une sympathie pour les gens qui
lui rendait bien parce que je pense que
les français l'ont aimé ils n'ont pas
toujours voté vraiment pour lui
massivement sauf une fois
jacques faty score de dictateur africain
92% des voix mais si ce n'est pas de sa
faute et donc par sahil avait il était
toujours passé de justesse c'est pour ça
qu'on a dit que voilà on avait aidé et
c'est bien toujours dit ce que vous avez
dit je voulais vous montrer le sketch
des guignols ou chirac apparaît avec des
couteaux dans le dos au moment de la
guerre avec edouard balladur parce que
doivent à la dure c'était son premier
ministre
voilà edouard balladur il dort balladur
a voulu ceux de l'europe l'europe voilà
que vous avez voulu vous présenter et
noir balladur en face de jacques chirac
pour les présidentielles de 95 vous
n'avez pas été au bout puisque voilà
jacques chirac qui est allé au bout bien
entendu en 95 c'était le deuxième tour
c'était face à jean marie le pen
enfin je vous demande
une annonce à laquelle tous les
observateurs s'attendaient tout de suite
la réaction de jacques chirac pas
surpris monsieur chirac
pourquoi trouve quand même pas vous
agace non ça ne savons pas non plus ça
me dit comment dieu ça me pique on a
beau être habitué
[ __ ] truc pas et ça fait quand même
mal au dos 1
alors il y avait il y avait il y avait
aussi le plus culte c'est aussi manger
des pommes
d'où est venue cette séquence manger des
pommes qu'il sait autour de la table
c'est le sert et que c'était le slogan 2
jacques chirac dans les guignols ont dit
on dit tout ce que c'est ça qui l'a fait
élire
oui ils appellent parce qu'un jour il a
fait un discours surréaliste où il a
parlé des pommes en train de kenzo homme
c'était 5 et pommes c'était bon pour la
santé
et c'est effectivement se réalise dans
ce contre les passants les hawks a
hérité les auteurs qui ont sorti manger
des pommes comme si c'était l'essentiel
de sa politique après donc il arrêtait
pas être manger des pommes
il avait aussi est un petit programme un
petit fascicule de programme et il a
couvert le mien c'était un pommier oui
mais ramené de la hausse il aurait
d'ailleurs il a utilisé parce que quand
il allait dans les marchés en campagne
etc qui voyait des gosses ils leur
disaient manger des pommes guignols
regarder et c'est lui qui a commencé
bah oui
co folio mange le pauvre chat s'il vous
plaît vous en prie ce n'est pas un
meeting s'il vous plaît [ __ ] j'ai
patates en ce moment moi je les bouffées
touché la fiac et louis donc vendredi
soir et présenter votre programme pour
de versailles mais [ __ ] je fait un
carton et louise le carton que je fais
mais c'est normal mais avec des gens du
rpr avait justement pas évident de faire
un carton avec les gens du rpr quand on
s'appelle cheikh en ce moment un bon les
était comme fou estérez un carton nous
ont même applaudi bernard pense c'est
vous dire comme ils sont faux merci
monsieur chat y'a pas de quoi bon moment
jacques chirac le vrai jacques chirac
parle de pommes regard des femmes est un
fruit
ça te quitter je les observe tous les
jours j'aime beaucoup les pas des
mangeurs de pommes
je vais rentrer chez moi en corrèze il
ya des pommiers qui sont des pommiers
touba très grande qualité il faut bien
le reconnaître et fait des pommes pour
faire un petit cidre qui n'a pas non
plus la grande prétention mais que
j'aime bien ah oui mais bon ce qui est
sûr c'est que si jamais jacques chirac
ne réussit pas dans ces entreprises
je n'en bouge comme vendeur de postes
[Applaudissements]
c'est le petit qui lui dit mangez des
pommes puisqu'ils devaient regarder les
guignols et donc et le prenez bien
mine de rien il a surfé sur sa sûrement
les les pommes et puis je vous dire on
en parlait tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
bernadette elle était très présente
aussi dans les guignols et il ya un
autre sketch culte
est-ce que vous rappelez la parodie de
pôle fiction ah oui ça faut parler de
ses sketches quand même qu'ils étaient
faits par des auteurs etc sans excès des
réalisateurs qui arrivait à rendre des
images avec des marionnettes ce qui
n'était pas évident c'était fou et puis
c'est vrai qu'il est arrivé à capter un
petit truc et jacques chirac je pense ça
a été le meilleur client le guignol
c'était c'était une source vraiment pour
vous une épuisable et regardez ce apple
fonctionne avec la coupe de jacques
chirac
c'était fou bon allez on y va c'est pile
polaire
salut les gars ça va vous n'avez pas le
droit non non faites moi confiance
edouard ira pas je vous assure je vous
jure qu'il ira pas faites moi confiance
c'est dingue ça a c'est un [ __ ]
miracle [ __ ] tu acheté des cds quoi ça
fait 20 ans que je fais ce boulot ça me
fait encore marie dingue ça
[Applaudissements]